[Applause]
please be seated
good morning everyone
first let me welcome you to Columbia
Business School's recognition ceremony
today we recognize the successful
completion of our Executive MBA program
by 280 amazing individuals as well as
some above and beyond accomplishments by
a number of our students faculty and
honored guests we're thrilled to have
you all together under one roof to share
in such a special day for the Columbia
Business School community so about the
weather
yeah we we tried to control as best we
could the weather gods into giving us
sunny and 75 degrees and as you can see
their reply seems to suggest that they
had something a little more challenging
in mind for us all a Japanese soldier in
the 17th century Yamamoto tsunetomo
wrote once that one must know the so
called lesson of a downpour a man caught
in a sudden rain and route dashes along
the road trying not to get wet or
drenched once one takes it for granted
that in rain he naturally gets wet he
can be in a tranquil frame of mind even
when soaps to the skin this lesson
applies to everything suna Tomos lesson
certainly applies to the experience that
you have had in the MBA program
you each heard during orientation how
this program might feel to you like
drinking from a firehose you've been
immersed in a rigorous classroom
environment swam the channels of
different career development
opportunities and had cups overflowing
in your social experiences combined with
your work and family endeavors I think
this qualifies as a thorough soaking and
yet our faculty and staff agree that you
have been the epitome of professional
engaged and attentive throughout your
time here
perhaps not tranquil but instead
resolute this is how you will be
remembered here at Columbia Business
School resolute resilient and receptive
to one of the deepest dives of your life
congratulations to you and to those who
supported you on this immense successful
journey
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
you this morning to our Dean
Glenn Hubbard Dean Hubbard was asked to
lead our community in July 2004 a
Columbia faculty member since 1988 he is
also the Russell L Carson professor of
finance and economics Dean Hubbard
received his BA and BS degrees summa
laude from the University of Central
Florida he also holds a M and PhD
degrees in economics from Harvard
University after graduating from Harvard
Dean Hubbard began his teaching career
at Northwestern University
moving to Columbia in 1988 he has been a
visiting professor at Harvard's Kennedy
School of Government and Harvard
Business School as well as at the
University of Chicago
Dean Hubbard has held the John M olan
fellowship at the National Bureau of
Economic Research
he teaches one of our most popular
courses entrepreneurial finance multiple
times each year in addition to writing
more than 100 scholarly articles in
economics and finance Dean Hubbard is
the author of three popular textbooks as
well as co-author of the ape trap hard
truths about ending poverty balance the
economics of great powers from ancient
Rome to modern America and healthy
wealthy and wise five steps to a better
healthcare system his commentaries
appear in Business Week The Wall Street
Journal the New York Times the Financial
Times The Washington Post Nikkei and the
daily ami ory as well as on TV and radio
in government
Dean Hubbard served as deputy assistant
secretary for tax policy at the US
Treasury Department and as chair of the
u.s. Council of Economic Advisers in the
corporate sector he is a director of ADP
Blackrock closed-end fund and MetLife
Dean Hubbard is co-chair of the
committee on capital markets regulation
and is a Past Chair of the Economic Club
of New York ladies and gentlemen please
join me in welcoming to the podium our
Dean Glenn Hubbard
thanks Michael good morning everybody I
want to welcome you on behalf of all of
my colleagues to this recognition
ceremony for the 140 members of the BA
class the hundred and six members of the
e/m class and 34 members of the Americas
class and all of our graduates a special
congratulations give yourselves another
round of applause you all you all are
extraordinary classes and an
extraordinarily diverse group that
represents really every possible
industry and background from finance and
technology healthcare consulting media
marketing you call among you 37
different countries home from Peru and
Poland to Haiti and Hongkong and Russia
you speak 24 different languages
including Hindi Hebrew Japanese
Portuguese and I am told by my
colleagues English you are incredibly
accomplished to boot more than a quarter
of you entered the class with at least
one other advanced degree under your
belt and you will find among you a
racecar driver a professional football
player
surfers skiers a sommelier a coffee
taster and a bagpipe player perhaps some
of the most talented among you are the
parents in your class
an impressive 22 that's right 22 of you
welcome to child during your time in the
program and let's not forget about
let's not forget about those partners
spouses children and loved ones who
supported you through residence weeks
through international seminars and
weekend spent in the library 27 have you
tied the knot during the program and 10
more of you got engaged congratulations
it is particularly gratifying for me and
for all of my colleagues on the faculty
to see how you exemplify some of the
things we all hold dear about this
school of course you're bright and
talented and committed to the principles
of leadership principles of
entrepreneurial thinking and you're
committed to one another now I know that
I could tell you 280 success stories
about today's graduate and I want to
tell you a few one of them is Dilip rau
who after eight years in Investment
Banking launched share bite a food
ordering marketplace with a social
impact mission after only two weeks at
Columbia dilip connected with an alum
who we eventually partnered with to
create a platform that enables users to
place a food order at the restaurant of
their choice for every order place share
bite then donates a meal to a child in
need in New York City or gives to the
charity of the users choice to date more
than 100 thousand such meals have been
donated and share bite is on its way to
achieving scalable impact and solving a
problem as a result of that big effort
yeah
as a result of that very big effort
gillip has her numerous accolades and
was suggested for the 2017 cohorts of
the Columbia green house and ie at
Columbia programs so congratulations
Lauren Anderson
Priscilla Guevara and Rachel Hawkins are
also on a social mission their startup
okay their startup flourish dot life is
a digital content platform and
marketplace for businesses that will
integrate social impact into their very
business strategy they offer intelligent
marketing capabilities predictive
analytics and social connections to the
consumer the business idea was hone
during the time in the program with
support of the language Center and
flourish dot life is now operating in
three metropolitan cities with an eye on
expansion so best of luck a few of your
other classmates also had ideas that
flourished
Salima rasullah launched a business in
education consulting during her time in
the program bloom education is a global
educational consulting firm that
provides both education and career
solutions to people and institutions
worldwide through both tailored strategy
and advice from guidance on the
admissions process to career
probabilities and possibilities bloom
aims to turn a typically stressful time
into a fun to a transformative
experience for students and for their
families the Salima credits her
classmates her entrepreneurship courses
and professors Noam Wasserman and Malia
Mason for helping guide her through the
startup process so I'm sure we'll be
hearing about more growth now speaking
of perennials Bradley Gordon recently
accepted a job with another blossom
inspired business bloom energy in
California he'll be working with a sales
team to get blooms technology solid
oxide fuel cells out into the market
Bloom's customers use these fuel cells
to reduce or eliminate reliance on the
electrical grid which of course equates
to a tremendous improvement in carbon
impact and an energy resilience Bradley
made the connection through the Columbia
alumni network and use the Career
Management Center to work through the
logistics in the negotiations process
Anna Pavlik MD not only got paid not
only got paid during her time in the
program but paid it for it she's a
professor in the Department of Medicine
at NYU Langone and co-director of their
melanoma program during her time in EMBO
she was a member of the international
team of clinical cancer investigators
who conducted the immunotherapy trials
for metastatic melanoma patients that
changed the overall survival rate from
5% of patients to 70% of patients she
developed she developed and presented a
business plan for the future state of
the NYU Cancer Center clinical trials
office to the senior leadership of the
hospital successfully securing an
additional five and a half million
dollars in funding from the hospital for
the project thank you Anna for this
important work you can now put saving
lives on your CV many of you many of you
made big leaps in your current careers
or took leaps of faith in the new ones
when she started the program
Jamie Lee was comfortable in her path as
a successful executive at General
Electric
but after courses with professors like
Paul Ingram and Wei Zheng and bill
Duggan and Paul Johnson Dan Eisenberg
and Bruce Draven a world of
possibilities opened up so she took a
job with current a start-up inside
General Electric a current she's working
to create intelligent environments by
incorporating smart sensors into all
kinds
lighting fixtures in a variety of
buildings to retail to manufacturing to
education for the first time she's
really not a hundred percent sure what
her next step will be but she feels
confident in the possibilities she'd
never have considered frankly two years
ago and the future looks pretty bright
now since starting the program Vasant
Ali has been hired into a fortune 500
company transitioning from independent
consulting and was promoted twice in
less than 18 months he credits Columbia
for playing a large role in the
promotion and Kimberly Warren was also
promoted during her time in the embassy
spreadin Tobal product sales in the
exponent of division of Verizon
congratulations I guess congratulations
squared and best of what now since the
day you all arrived everybody in the
school has challenged you to be active
to be contributing members of the
community and you've more than met this
challenge as students and I know you
will continue to do so as you join the
ranks of 44,000 men and women around the
world
as CBS alumni that community is more
vital than ever and the personal and
professional friendships that you have
created in your time here at Columbia
will form the foundation of many
lifelong friends and members in the
Columbia Business School community
you've learned a lot in your time here
but I just want to focus on two things
with you that a great business school
like this one can impart the first is
the observation that your MBA is like a
calling card that says to the world I am
entrepreneurial I am a problem solver I
can solve the whole puzzle not just a
piece of it and I can seize upon
opportunity in any environment second
mark of a great business school it
should and this one does prepare you for
a lifelong career in business in social
enterprise in public service
for all of you all of you it means not
just a skill set the things you have
literally learned but a mindset the
things you can now appreciate that will
help you succeed because you already
know a lot more than many less
experienced MBAs about what to expect
from your careers you know and we know
that the value of your degree and your
experience here will unfold over a
lifetime you are graduating from
business school in a period of very
exciting opportunity and needless to say
change in the world of business and you
no doubt do so with a perspective over
the past several years of business
cycles a transformative 21st century
curriculum has helped you unlock within
yourself how to create opportunity in
any environment and thanks to this
school's unique position here in New
York
you've really benefited from an
unrivaled access the myriad industry and
visionary business leaders the
reputation and strength of the alumni
and the school has equipped you with the
knowledge and access you really need to
help yourself make the lasting impact I
know you can as an alum which you now
will be this network will provide you
with the connections to foster your own
creativity invite your own
entrepreneurial thinking and open your
own doors to opportunity and these tools
will give you the confidence and ability
to succeed on your terms you couldn't be
better prepared but I have to be honest
with you with the rewards of your MBA
also come responsibility that is what
does it really mean to be a graduate of
a place like Columbia Business School I
open expect we all hope and expect that
as you take big strides in your career
that you are inspired to remember new
generations of students and remember the
support that you received in your time
here as a proud steward of the Columbia
Business School brand
adding value to the community so what
happens this morning now in one sense
the familiar sense the bubble over your
head since you will graduate you will
become part of the school's alumni
network throughout the world like so
many people before you and you're going
to make a mark I know you'll be inspired
by your predecessors like Jerry spirally
Cooperman Henry Kravis Lulu Wong Robert
Smith or Russ Carson Tracy Travis Sally
Krawczyk Warren Buffett Jaimie Kern Lima
John Martin Tim Campos and thousands of
names that I convention 44,000 such that
community is your community be sure you
leverage it and do so for a lifetime now
on days like this I actually prefer a
different word it's a more old-fashioned
word commencement because that word has
an explicit reference to a beginning you
will continue a life of engagement and
business and society but you're
beginning it at a new level and as you
leave here remember again that the value
of your embassy Rian's will unfold over
time what I look forward to hearing from
you in the years to come is what you
didn't expect but you still got anyway
from the program and from your degrees
I'm looking forward to hearing from you
what this mindset I refer to will give
you your company in the world but I want
to leave you with a form most of all
never forget never forget what a noble
calling business itself is and the power
that lies within each and every one of
you today and going forward to transform
the lives of other business leaders and
entrepreneurs along with communities and
nations around the world remember that
your MBA today is a master of choices
what matters most to me what matters
most to your friends and family has not
been changed jingling in your pocket
after commence
thing but to change you're going to make
in the world congratulations to all of
you give yourselves another round of
applause before I blow away up here it
is now my pleasure to turn the
microphone over to Kellie Martin Blanca
[Applause]
Thank You Dean Hubbard welcome everyone
and congratulations
the Executive MBA commitment to
excellence award was established in
memory of professor Margaret K Chandler
to recognize a faculty member for his or
her outstanding contributions to the
class for the M Baracus class this
year's recipient is Bob Bontempo Bob
received his PhD in social psychology
from the University of Illinois in 1989
where his dissertation was funded by a
grant from the MacArthur Foundation he
went on to become a fellow at the
Stanford Center for Advanced Study in
the behavioral sciences his research has
been published in a wide variety of
journals in Europe Asia and the United
States and his perspectives on
management are featured regularly in The
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
The Economist as well as network news
broadcast
bob is a leading adviser to senior
executives worldwide in his industry
practice focused on building executive
development as an accordionist a
political tea director of Columbia
Business School's emerging leader
development program he has been in the
forefront of executive and
organizational development for more than
20 years
his current consulting clients include
the Federal Reserve and the United
Nations in addition to winning the
Singhvi prize for outstanding leadership
in the classroom bob has a number of
teaching awards from Columbia Business
School
the University of Illinois and was named
one of the top US MBA professors by
Businessweek magazine please join me in
congratulating Bontempo and welcome
Thank You Kelly I'm going to start by
saying thank you for inviting me to be
here today it's deeply satisfying that
I've been asked to come and have a
chance to say hello students often ask
how one class differs from another and
what was your experience and of course
you always have to say well this was a
very special group and it was wonderful
but I think I'm here today because this
was a very special group and the cohort
the cohort of EMBO America worked
together in a unusually productive and
communal way and I think it exemplifies
what we try to create here in our sense
of a learning community and so I thank
you for that it was a great experience
for me now
I have a very brief few minutes to make
maybe one point that much of the course
that I teach is focused on the idea of
feedback we learn through feedback we
can get better through feedback for me
being invited to be here today is the
nicest kind of feedback that I can get
but as leaders we can continue to
develop and grow by paying close
attention to how our actions are
impacting those around us whether
they're helping us achieve our goals I'm
confident the members of the EM book
class will continue on the path that
we've begun the path of lifelong
learning and continuous personal
improvement by being here today you've
already accomplished something that's
quite remarkable and I have every
confidence you'll continue as you move
forward but I want to take this
opportunity maybe one more time to teach
you one thing it's another aspect of
feedback it's not your ability to learn
and monitor your progress from the
feedback you get from others it's to
think about the impact that some special
moment has had on you
I'd like you to reflect for one second I
bet many of you here today can think
about a transformational comment or a
special moment that somebody had with
you maybe they didn't even appreciate it
maybe it was some of you work with it
encouraged you to come to the program
maybe was a high school teacher that
recognized you had a special talent
maybe with a family member that gave you
a piece of encouragement when you really
needed it that person probably doesn't
realize the tremendous transformational
impact it had on you and that's kind of
a shame part of the problem is we often
take it for granted how other people
feel about it but today is a very
special moment we came together in this
unusual circumstance we're dressed up in
funny robes so it's a special chance and
it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
let's start by giving people feedback
about the impact they've had on you
let's start right now on any of these
people over here know these folks have
traveled in some cases very far and made
great sacrifices they're staying in the
hotel they dragged their relatives along
they're sitting in the rain let's give
them a hand right now and let them know
how much we really appreciate
they need to know how much you
appreciate what they've done for them
don't take it for granted that they hear
that now let me go further you realize
that for you to be here there were
probably lots of folks who were
inspirational and made a difference they
might be some of these folks here the
tremendous staff the huge program of the
Columbia folks who make this all
possible
but there's a lot of other folks I like
to think of the caterers the people that
make the gallons of coffee available
that for me at least class teaching
would not be possible right
if dozens and dozens of people along the
way who made a real difference and I'm
asking you to make sure that you let
them know how important it was in the
same way that other people have inspired
you so in closing my basic messages you
have had the benefit of a moment here
there of somebody who may be transformed
your life let them know but the next
point is you're now leaders you're now
graduates and as such it's now your
responsibility to become that
transformational inspirational person
who gives other people feedback and in
the same way that other folks have
lifted up you to be here today it's now
your chance to be that inspirational
transformational leader that inspires
other folks so as you go forth I wish
you the best of luck and my best wishes
as you continue to grow and become the
best person you can be
congratulations
[Applause]
Thank You bomb it is now my pleasure to
introduce Becky van de Pierre who was
chosen by her classmates in the MV
Americas class house today's speaker
Becky started her career as a journalist
working as a writer and editor for
companies including Fairfax Media levy
net and Yahoo she came to Columbia as
she officially switched her career to
work in her family office in Toronto
that said Becky's favorite job is being
a mom to her two young daughters Libby
and Katie Becky has a Bachelor of Arts
from Duke University as well as a master
of journalism from Australia's
University of Technology in Sydney she
is in her words super excited to add an
MBA from Columbia to that list Becky the
feeling is mutual
I also want to thank you and your
parents mr. mrs. Gardner who are here
somewhere for hosting us and making us
feel so welcome in Toronto a couple of
years ago please join me in welcoming
Becky to the podium
hi everyone thank you so much for having
me here today I'm just so honored to be
chosen as the NV America's class Speaker
for me this is a really really big deal
being up here makes me feel like a
slightly older lightly chubbier slightly
less well-dressed version of Reese
Witherspoon's elwood in 2001 masterpiece
coming-of-age tale Legally Blonde except
instead of skipping frat parties and
overcoming harsh blonde stereotypes to
eventually triumph as class speaker at
Harvard Law School I had to figure out
how to manage parenting my two
incredible young daughters my life is a
journalist and the 13th percentile
quantitative ranking I earned the first
time I took the GMAT to get to this
outstanding place Columbia Business
School one thing Ellen I did have in
common is that we both had our hearts
broken before we started school she by
her preppies no-good boyfriend me when
my 10-year marriage ended three days
before I was set to get on a plane and
fly to New York City for my first day of
class getting on that plane I was scared
I didn't know what to expect of the next
20 months at Columbia let alone the next
20 years of my life what I did know is
that my life is going to change and like
it or not it was going to change right
now what I soon found out was that that
change was going to be great
of course my classes here at Columbia
were excellent the 20 months I spent at
this university changed my career and
the way I operate my family office every
day but what undoubtedly changed me the
most are my classmates these people I am
proud and fortunate to call my friends
stepping into Warren Hall on day one I
found myself amongst some of the
smartest funniest kindest most
interesting and supportive people not
just that I have ever met but that I
believe exists in this country and on
this
Planet Miami America's cluster r32
remarkable people who on that very first
day didn't know me from the next person
standing in line at IT services but who
embraced me right away for who I was
regardless of what I was going through
they saw me immediately at a time when I
was lost to myself I soon learnt that I
wasn't the only one giving the middle
finger to life's obstacles put aside for
a moment the fact that we all completed
our MBAs while working full-time and
that we were traveling from all parts of
the world just to attend class we had
real life happening to us too
one of my classmates for example was a
successful surgeon in the height of his
career when a car accident put a stop to
that but instead of feeling sorry for
himself he started over in the business
world and came to Colombia to cement his
new path others in my class were dealing
with health issues family issues
infertility or too much fertility a
hearty congrats to all the new parents
guys yes and many were doing their MBA
in a second or third language when there
were times I could barely understand
what was going on in my first my
professors quite literally some of the
smartest people on the planet are no
less inspiring he may tell you a story
when he speaks he may not but just
Google one of my absolute favorite
professors Paul Johnson plus SEC and
you'll know what I'm talking about
this man was one of many people here who
showed me by example what it looks like
to take life's PS and to use it as handy
fertilizer to grow something better I
tell my friends in Toronto that when I
was at Columbia I worked harder than I
ever had in my life and that my end goal
my ultimate dream goal was to achieve
mediocrity it sounds funny I know but
the truth is I'm proud to be considered
average amongst this group of phenomenal
people just being around them made me
want to push myself more aim for better
and actually see success is more than I
thought I was capable of look I want to
spare you any platitudes I could give at
this moment I don't feel that I'm in any
position to offer you thoughts about
what the future looks like or give you
advice on how to act as business leaders
I'm still learning from you and I hope I
always will be this is not that kind of
speech what I can tell you is that this
experience has taught me that it's
always possible to take steps to make
life better and being open minded and
inclusive like my classmates were with
me is not just a nice thing to do but it
can really change someone's life for the
better this is my opportunity to express
my heartfelt gratitude to you my friends
and mentors without whom I would not
have been able to recognize the worst
time in my life as really my evolution
into a stronger happier and more
fulfilled person I am so lucky to have
found myself at Columbia when I did to
have been with you incredible people and
I am so lucky and so privileged to
represent you here today I'm especially
lucky to have my two daughters Libby and
Katie somewhere out here in the audience
fingers crossed they have put down their
iPads and I've actually noticed that I'm
talking
because even if they can't yet
appreciate this full circle moment for
me that can be a part of this
once-in-a-lifetime celebration of the
people who changed my life thank
[Applause]
for the MBA York Saturday class
this year's Executive MBA commitment to
excellence award recipient is Professor
Paul Ingram Paul Ingram is the kravitz
professor of Business at Columbia
Business School and the faculty director
of the Columbia advanced management
program Columbia's flagship residential
program for senior executives around the
globe
professor Ingram earned his PhD from
Cornell University and he served on the
faculty of Carnegie Mellon University
before coming to Columbia he has held
visiting professorships
at Tel Aviv University Shanghai Jiaotong
University and the University of Toronto
the courses he teaches on management and
strategy draw from his research on
organizations in the United States
Canada Israel Scotland England China
Korea and Australia his research has
been published in more than 60 articles
book chapters and books professor
Ingram's current research examines the
intersection between culture and social
networks at Columbia Business School
professor Ingram has received the deans
award for Teaching Excellence won the
commitment to excellence award as voted
on by graduating embo students four
times and three times has been chosen by
graduating and the students to deliver
the keynote speech at their commencement
ceremony please join me in
congratulating and welcoming them to the
podium
professor Paul Ingram
[Applause]
I'm thrilled to be here to recognize the
great achievement of the class of 2017
graduating from the Columbia Business
School is an achievement for you but
it's also an achievement for your
families the spouses children parents
and friends who've supported you I hope
they enjoy this celebration as much as
you do because they've earned it
the same is true for me I'm here because
of the support of my beautiful wife Ally
my wonderful daughters Alexandra and
Amanda and I'm very happy that they're
here today I'm particularly happy that
Amanda is here to see me today because
she is almost five years old and she
still doesn't really seem to believe
that I'm a teacher the first time I told
her I was a teacher she said dad and you
can't be a teacher because you're a boy
I think I think I successfully convinced
her that boys can be teachers although
it probably won't help my argument that
the first time she sees me at work I'm
wearing a red dress
but I think the real reason that Amanda
doesn't think I'm a teacher is because
her image of the school is the yellow
room at the Park West Montessori and of
course the yellow room is nothing like
the Columbia Business School think about
it in the yellow room the students
struggle through lessons until they can
take a nap in class I know nothing like
that ever happened in Warren Hall and a
Saturday afternoon I would be deeply
shocked if any of you ever wanted to
take a nap in the middle of one of my
classes in the yellow room the students
are fed snacks constantly their whole
day is structured around lunch it's
almost like it's almost like the
teachers use food to keep the kids under
control and of course we'd never stoop
to a trick like that at the Columbia
Business School and in the yellow room
Amanda tells me the teachers say that
they're trying to help you but they ask
you to do things that you don't want to
do and sometimes sometimes they're just
scary well maybe on that one dimension
the Columbia Business School is a little
like the yellow room actually the more I
think about it I'm not so sure that
yellow room really is that different
from the Columbia Business School in
fact 25 years from now if Amanda does a
degree here
I think she'll recognize the
similarities maybe then she'll finally
believe that her father is a teacher as
a teacher I'm happy to accept this award
I'm very fond of this class recently I
flipped through the Columbia Facebook
pictures for the class as I looked at
all of you I found myself smiling one
reason that I was smiling was that you
were all smiling in your pictures I've
never seen a group that looks so happy
to be joining the Columbia Business
School I also smiled because of the
things I remembered as I looked at the
pictures I remembered the first time I
met all of you in an orientation session
and I remembered hundreds of moments
students then in class and outside of
class they included each and every one
of you I also look back at the work that
your class produce one of the things I
looked at was a set of values that you
identified in a class exercise
looking at cluster II in cluster M I was
struck by how much you have in common
for both sections the top values were
happiness integrity and achievement
think about those values happiness
integrity and achievement I hope you
realize how aligned this day is with
those values you've achieved something
great you've done it with integrity and
right now I hope you're as happy as you
deserve to be of course the values of
clusters a and M were not exactly the
same cluster II you differentiated
yourself by having maximize income as
one of your top values I bet you're
happy right now because you think you
don't have to keep writing checks to
Colombia I'm sorry to have to tell you
that I think Dean Hubbard has a
different plan section M you stood out
because instead of maximizing income you
had recognition at the top value I know
that means that you want me to finish
the short speech so you can get up on
stage and get your own recognition well
standing between Section M and
recognition is an uncomfortable place to
be so I'm going to give you one last
thought and then get out of the way in
class we talked about the fact that
people are happiest when they're
pursuing a dream and that actually
achieving a dream it's a mixed blessing
because it can leave you Amos I
suggested in class that if you ever
achieved a dream you should savor it for
a little while but then quickly move
forward by identifying a new aspiration
and I'll say the same thing to you today
you've achieved something fabulous and
you really should celebrate it enjoy
this weekend with your family and
friends and be proud of yourself
as I am proud of all of you but don't
wallow in it come Monday morning start
thinking about the next great thing you
are going to achieve and make your new
goal worthy of you
Robert Louis Stevenson wrote that it is
better to travel hopefully than to
arrive my hope for you is that you
travel hopefully and I'm so grateful to
be here to see you begin your
journeys thank you and congratulations
[Applause]
I'm now happy to introduce you to cush
tota who was chosen by his fellow
students to be the graduation speaker
for the MBA New York Saturday class
push is a director at Barclays and is
the global head of client strategy for
their currencies business he's been with
Barclays since 2008 including three
years in Hong Kong as CEO for their Asia
equity business cush graduated from
Stevens Institute of Technology in
hoboken Co Ducks in 2005 with a degree a
dual degree a Bachelor of Science and
computer engineering and a master's in
telecom management as an embassy dn't
cush has served as the career
representative for cluster II and also
served on the MV Advisory Council he's
originally from India and lives in New
Jersey with his wife Deepti and his two
kids
Yash and Anya please join me in
welcoming and congratulating push
okay Thank You Dean Hubbard the Kelly
amber team distinguished faculty friends
and family and the fellow members of
class of 17 congratulations we made it
each of us stands here today to express
our gratitude to all of you and I'm
privileged and honored to speak today on
behalf of my fellow classmates member
Saturday and I want to talk about two
theories talk about community and talk
about self-reflection let's talk about
community first many Saturdays
block weeks weeknights later we all
stand here today looking back to what
seems to me just like one long day you
know bright and early started palisades
before we came back to Warren where we
were welcomed by an amazing spread of
breakfast then only got thinner and
thinner at the terms progressed whether
it was the imbalanced account
receivables in accounting in the summer
or the drifting capital ratios in
corporate finance or the not so linear
utility curves in microeconomics we knew
there was always a way to Bernheim at
the end of it all and that's thanks to
our social shares location chip we
survived the core we survived the cord
thanks to Sarah and Kathy or academic
reps for their weekly emails which we
all barely missed during the electives
we endured the block week especially the
one with Dean Hubbard with some long
nights we braved the polar vortex and a
cab ride or a walk back home laughter
not so timely dismissal of classes but
it wasn't easy right it wasn't easy but
there always someone you could count on
to help and it starts with everybody in
our cohorts eat and for me we stood the
test of multiple case studies every week
followed by everybody here who always
came together to celebrate each of our
milestones today is all about us and not
one person alone the simple fact is that
our experience was never just about one
Saturday one course or one particular
deliverable
it was always about each other we
questioned each other we question
ourselves but we all view as a community
from here on though it marks the start
of a new day which brings me to my other
themes self reflect we will all reflect
on our business school experience to
determine the main tenants that will
shape who we are some will finally
remember that wall skew is not an
indicator of market sentiment some will
finally remember this sloppy fantasy
football pics or the Star Wars Halloween
costumes not to mention the fact that a
room plus the 50 people at least you
were bound to have the same birthday I
think we need one more which is
embracing our change perspectives and
the self reflect as we all reluctantly
crawl back into the life after school
and we draw our own valuation models
from here on we run the risk of letting
dry mundane issues creep back in and
fill it out fill up our lives so we
repeat each day what we do every day but
it's somewhere in the same repetition
are the same frustrations that we all
walked away from and came to CVS two
years ago this place has taught us to
approach life with greater insight and
the question what is presented to you
until you truly believe in it for
yourself it is challenge us to identify
and explore opportunities and
inefficiencies in the world around us
everyone here is an incredible story
I wish I could share with you all of
them so they could leave a lasting
impression on you just like they haven't
made
Dileep Rao who saw an opportunity in the
new york food ordering market that
combines food delivery with a social
mission and a Pavelec who continues the
research of metastatic melanoma and has
saved lives of many and Danny cow who
inspires the devil stop learning
he's a doctor he's a lawyer and now he's
the Business School graduate he lined up
at GSK offering help to those who were
affected by the executive order on
immigration earlier in the year GD was
just some of the people who continued to
inquire continue to shape and this power
of inquiry shape is rooted in the
connections we've all made and the
questions we have asked and today I know
it's the community sitting before me
that made and still makes this program
and this place so difficult to leave
today I also know is the day to
celebrate the personal sacrifices the
perseverance and the sheer will of my
grandparents and my parents who had very
simple beginnings play lick with
hardships the journey of our family from
a remote village in rural India where my
grandfather grew up with only two set of
clothes and we have to walk for an hour
each each way to get to the nearest
school the Columbia University today is
a strong testament to their hard work
and zeal for learning now it will only
be fair for all of us to thank our
spouses and partners and I want to give
them a round of applause so let's hear
it for them
I want to thank my wife Deepti I think
we all are spouses and partners an
extraordinary amount of gratitude and
there in my mind the real graduates
today in addition to being supportive
and accommodating of our time away from
them and from home in many cases they've
also had to take care of our kids and I
know my two kids Irish and Anya are
quite a delightful for a very handful
Bunch so we couldn't have done this
without the smiles on their faces and so
in closing we should all look back on
this a multiple journey would be
gratitude to our families to our friends
to our faculty only to look forward with
the hope that we promised each other to
continue to self-reflect and not let
ourselves sink back into a numbing
routine and that we live with a
determined strive to scale higher feats
for as long as we do hashtag why CBS
thank
Thank You cush the executive the embas
New York sorry
Friday Saturday class has chosen Paul
Johnson as the recipient of the
Executive MBA commitment to excellence
award this year Paul is the founder of
MacUser investment advisors a private
investment partnership that he started
in 2003 he is co-author of pitch the
perfect investment the essential guide
to winning on Wall Street scheduled to
be published in July of this year he was
a contributing annotator to the most
important thing illuminated by Howard
Marks and co-authored both the history
of value investing at Columbia Business
School a century of ideas and the
gorilla gang picking winners in
high-technology Paul has been an adjunct
professor at Columbia Business School
since 1992
he has taught 38 courses on securities
analysis and value investing to more
than 1,800 students he holds an MBA in
finance from the executive program at
the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton
School of Business and a BA in economics
from the University of California at
Berkeley please join me in welcoming
Paul Johnson
[Applause]
apparently the weather is part of the
exchange program of London
lovely um Pete it's just students
faculty parents and family very
important fellow speakers in Dean
Hubbard it is a great honor to be here
to accept the Teaching Excellence Award
as many of you know and Kelly pointed
out I received an Executive MBA like you
26 years ago on a 75 degree day I'd like
to believe I have some sense of what
you're feeling today perhaps it's
because I was invited to speak at
graduation that I have been reflecting
recently on the value of an MBA since
they teach value investing it's only
natural that my first approach to
answering this question would be to
analyze the question by using the same
methods I teach in my class besides to a
man with a hammer every problem looks a
little bit like a nail I hope well my
students remember that we separate the
value of steady-state from the value of
growth for the steady-state cash flow I
decided to use your income from when you
entered the program and for the value of
growth at the value of value of growth
cash flows I use the income after
graduating I figured that we could
determine the value of your MBA by
comparing your steady-state value with
the value of your growth although I
didn't have data specifically for each
of you I thought it fair to take an
average of income when you came into the
program versus what is tomato earn in
the future as a class as they entered
the data into my valuation model in
Excel like I showed you in class it
dawned on me that maybe I've been
teaching value investing too long
as I pondered the question a bit further
I realized that using a DCF to value
your experience at Columbia is somewhat
absurd
although the quantitative approaches
you've learned in your courses have
great power when applied to the correct
situations I think that this would be a
silly approach in this situation I hope
you would all agree that it's not about
the growth and income the present value
of future cash flows or any other
specific financial metric the value of
the MBA is how they experience change
you as a person many of you have told me
that your time at Columbia gave you
experiences you would not have had
exposed you to topics that you would not
you did not know existed and most
importantly allowed you to meet interact
and be challenged by individuals you
would not have met if you would not
attended the program these experiences
have changed fundamentally your
expectations ambitions and what you want
to achieve in life simply put you are
not the same person you were 20 20
months ago it would be hard to value
these transformational experiences in
terms of money the question you now face
is where do you go from here the first
thing you will notice is that you will
get your weekends back although without
some planning you'll be shocked how
quickly the time gets absorbed into the
ordinary aspects and the daily routines
of life I would recommend spending some
time thinking about how you want to
allocate your time and not just your
newly returned weekends many of you will
soon discover if you have not realized
already the time is a finite and limited
resource as I observe in the final
lecture in my course if you want to know
what's important to a person look how
they allocate their time and if you want
to know what's important to you look at
how you spend your time I became an
adjunct professor 25 years ago in
September of 1992 a work colleague of
mine named Charlie Wolfe walked across
the hall between our offices to see if I
wanted to teach a Columbia Business
School I told Charlie that sure I would
love to teach when I'm old like
Charlie was in his early 60s at the time
which does not seem that old to me right
now Charlie had been a tenured professor
at Columbia but left academia to become
Wall Street analyst he returned to CBS
each fall to teach a class on security
analysis but had person needed someone
to cover for him because of personal
conflict that year I graduated from
Wharton only the year before and felt
too young and inexperienced to teach an
MBA course at a leading business school
Charlie was persuasive however and I
agreed to teach the course which was
scheduled to start three weeks later
being 31 years old at the time and have
never taught anything in my life I was
incredibly nervous as I headed to
Columbia for my first day of teaching
the students were receptive to their
young professor and I fell in love with
being in the classroom in that first
3-hour lecture I've been coming back
ever since the students continue to be
receptive and I love teaching more now
than when I started
they completed teaching my 38 semester
long course this term and if the
schedule holds I will teach this fall my
40 of course is CBS on my 25th
anniversary of being an adjunct
professor I'm delighted to that I said
yes
I started when I was 12 years old I know
some of you were doing the math
I'm delighted that I said to charli's
request because they have found a
passion and teaching that no other
activity in my life ever provided I
often joke that my curiosity has OCD I
found that teaching allows me to forum
to continue my education
although students seem to appreciate the
content of my lectures no one has
learned more in my classroom than I have
and I have all of you to thank for that
receiving the Excellence in teaching
award is a wonderful recognition of the
efforts I've applied to becoming an
accomplished professor thank you when I
sat in your chair waiting for my diploma
I had no idea what the next 25 years
would bring it proved to be a journey
that far exceeded my wildest imagination
some of which was exciting and rewarding
while other parts challenged me to my
core your path will be different than
mine and from each other some of the
adventures will blow your mind while
other parts will test your character but
they will all form your life the world
is changing at a faster pace than any
time in our collective history and you
will not only have a front-row seat to
those developments you and your
classmates will be the leaders that
direct and manage that change I hope you
take with you on that journey what you
have learned from your experience at
Columbia Business School thank
thank you Paul it is my pleasure to
introduce behad ahmed who was chosen by
the m Bannu York Friday Saturday class
Fahad was born and raised in New York
Hudson Valley he is the second of four
sons to parents who instilled in each of
their sons the importance of hard work
and living life with integrity values he
believes brought him to Columbia
Business School
Fahad has found great fulfillment
helping his classmates tell their
stories as a part of the school cBS
matters program because as he found out
everyone has a story to tell he holds a
Bachelor degree in chemistry and a
master's degree in public administration
he currently works as a manager at
Deloitte in the life sciences and
healthcare sector prior to joining CBS
if you asked Fahad to describe himself
in one sentence he would say I'm a New
York Mets fan now he proudly says I'm a
member of CBS MBA class of 2017 and a
New York Mets fan please join me in
welcoming Fahad to the podium
well good afternoon to everyone -
associate dean Malone Dean hubber thank
you both very much for being here and
thank you to Kelly for that introduction
and can't tell you how much we
appreciated your entire staff for all of
your support
especially to Susan's fees who has been
described as silent Thunder of the
administration
she has been incredibly helpful to all
of us and really a great friend to
everyone and most of all I want to thank
all of my classmates here for this
opportunity I will miss you all very
much when this class first came together
I'll be honest I was impressed one day
when I heard one day when I learned that
we're a class comprised of top business
men and women we were consultants and we
were marketers we were doctors and
scientists we were entrepreneurs and
veterans it was fascinating learning
about these accomplishments and all the
various careers that we all have all of
us had extraordinary resumes even before
we came to Columbia Business School but
in those early days something happened a
change took place the character of a
class started to take shape we care less
about who we were as professionals we
cared more about who we are as people to
relationships formed and collectively we
learned who we are as a class as a class
were fearless before this program we all
had other commitments we all had our
work lives in our personal lives yet we
chose to take this on we chose at a
full-time MBA course load to our lives
even though we knew it would be
difficult we chose to do this we show
that fearlessness comes in many
different forms early on this program we
identified our values we picked a value
word now no one here could have expected
how important this would be because no
one could have ever predicted what this
world would become and where we are
expected where our values are tested
daily and we are expected to stand up
for them
those values that we hold important as
individuals but also as a class in our
own ways whenever our values are
threatened we have shown that we are
fearless if there is a need for
conversation we come together and speak
if there is a need to March we March
we are also persistent for 20 straight
months during every class every project
every exam we pushed ourselves to learn
just a little bit more to add this line
to our resume we pushed ourselves to
create and foster relationships
relationships because we understood that
our time together in this setting was
short we never went halfway we never
quit
finally we're optimistic no matter how
tough the workload was no matter what
challenges we face inside and outside of
the classroom we remain optimistic we
remained confident that the work we were
accomplishing with places in the best
position to meet our goals even when the
wave optimism was small we stayed
optimistic we never let ourselves wear
out we never let our frustrations get us
down fearlessness persistence optimism
these are the characteristics that make
up this class we will need these
characteristics as we face our next
challenge now that we have decided now
that we have completed this experience
we need to decide what do we do next
what do we do next this curriculum
taught us about creating shareholder
value but it also made us wonder what's
more important shareholder value or
social words is our responsibility to
the CEO at the top or to the community
as a whole it's adding the next line to
our resume the only thing that matters
some of us have already started to
answer this question we've contributed
to charities we've been involved in
social group we've served this country
we are already out there working to do
good in the world for others this is our
second chance a second chance to change
the direction of our careers to do good
- feeling completely fulfilled that we
are adding real value because this world
is what it is today it's time to step up
there's no riding off into the sunset
after this there is no going back to who
we used to be not now not after this
program this is not persistence
there's no optimism in this in fact it's
a disservice to the fearlessness we've
shown so far you see the character of
our class our education and our
experience makes us uniquely qualified
to create meaningful change this is what
separates the executive mba program from
all other programs at this university no
other program boasts more success
stories no other program boasts more
networks created this program is truly
the best of what Columbia University
offers it is exceptional and it is
exceptional because you all are
exceptional and I truly believe this and
if anyone is doubting this just look at
where you are consider what you have
just accomplished despite the pressures
of a full-time job despite your
obligations to your family and your
friends
and despite managing all the
distractions of this remarkable City we
committed ourselves to this program we
committed ourselves to each other and
it's this commitment that is the
difference between us and all of our
competitors because unlike them cBS
matters we are exceptional
we are exceptional and we have great
opportunities in front of us great
opportunities to let us add real value
you see I firmly believe that great
opportunities look for exceptional
people to lead the best part is that
these opportunities are already here
right now because there is an absence of
leadership in the world leaders who are
fearless leaders who can persist when
things get tough and leaders who are
able to instill optimism over the past
20 months we have proved that we are
this leader so what do we do next what
we do next is seize this opportunity and
fill this absence yes the work will be
difficult we have no reason to be
intimidated because this experience
because of this experience we are all
bound together your struggle is our
struggle your success is our success and
it's the weight of these great
opportunities become too much for your
shoulders to bear
remember we go together so class of 2017
it's time to step up be fearless be
persistent be optimistic it's time we
recognize our abilities and seize this
opportunity presented to us it's time we
become the leaders we always wanted our
leaders to be because what we do next
will not just be another accomplishment
added as a line to our resume what we do
next will make it so that we never have
to submit a resume ever again
congratulations and thank you very much
for this opportunity
thank you now it is my privilege to
introduce our keynote speaker Mary beech
is the executive vice president chief
marketing officer at Kate speedin
company responsible for providing
leadership and direction on all
marketing and brand creative strategies
prior to this role Mary spent several
years at Ralph Lauren leading the
company's marketing function for retail
in 2000 she joined the Walt Disney
Company and spent the early part of her
career defining and launching the Disney
Princess brand in 2006 Mary was
appointed vice president general manager
animation consumer products at Disney
Pixar leading all marketing and license
category performance for Disney and
Pixar filmed entertainment and grew to
be the senior vice president of this for
billion-dollar retail business in
addition to all of her professional
achievements mary has become a great
friend to Columbia Business School she
regularly gets lectures in the classroom
and as a class fit is a student favorite
speaker at many of the CBS conferences
having had the chance to get to know her
over the past year she is incredibly
kind and incredibly generous generous
and we are very lucky to have her part
of the CBS community please join me in
welcoming Mary Beach
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone thank you fog
thank you to Dean Kelly and Dean Hubbard
and to all of you for having me here
today to join you in your celebration in
the second grade at the father-daughter
dance at my all-girls school the dads
were asked what they wanted their
daughters to be when they grew up now my
dad didn't give any of the obvious
answers of doctor or lawyer or teacher
like the other dads
he said I want her to be a contributing
member of society I was seven I had no
idea what this meant but this was a man
who charged me rent to use our lawn from
my lemonade stand and then further
charged me for the supplies for the
lemonade putting me in the red before I
even left the front porch I took to
selling rocks on the vacant sidewalk
across the street because the margins
were better so even at seven I knew my
dad was no dummy and that this
expectation about being a contributing
member of society that's pretty serious
stuff
so as I set out to write this speech I
thought of my dad's wish because the
edict before you even set foot on this
campus you already were contributing
members of society but then something
made you want to up the ante on that
contribution don't get me wrong many
people want to do more and achieve more
but not many are willing to give up two
years of Friday night date nights and
Saturday brunches in order to achieve it
so while I'm here under the auspices of
inspiring you honestly I am the one
who's inspired you wanted to do more and
you did something about it and something
big you are each of you an inspiration
for that alone now like all of you I'm
pretty confident that I did become a
contributing member of society but my
interpretation of this expectation has
changed dramatic
over time I was reminded of this
evolution about six weeks ago in a
nondescript building on First Avenue
where I was undergoing an MRI to find
out if some tumors they had found in my
kidneys for cancerous now I realize this
just took a morbid turn so please know
that the tumors were benign and that the
worst part of the experience was waiting
for the results and the Taylor Swift
music that I in a moment of panic
requested played during the test but
here's what became crystal clear to me
inside that MRI tube with T Swift piped
into my ears
you better be utterly at peace with your
contribution to this world our moments
like that moments when you are
completely alone with who you are and
what you've done are going to be a
little tough while I hope you never face
that particular situation you will at
some point face a moment where you are
utterly alone with who you are and it's
in that moment you can take an inventory
of your contributions and come out
humming welcome to New York and feeling
damn near giddy then you've been pretty
successful indeed successes are often
viewed like notches in a belt I'm
confident and I have heard all this
morning that you already have a long
list of successes and today's MBA is yet
another you'll soon add that list with
businesses you start titles you achieve
deals you do Fast Company articles
written about you and TED Talks you give
but I would suggest that in your most
alone moment it's not these types of
successes that will come into your head
this morning I want to suggest you
several different ways of looking at
success and ultimately your contribution
to society first success is figuring out
what you enjoy and doing that what you
enjoy is almost never the answer you
give it a cocktail party when asked what
do you do I don't enjoy being a CMO I
enjoy working with super creative people
helping them figure out how to make
their creativity have the biggest impact
on the world in which I operate this has
been the single consistent thread
running through my career figure out
sooner rather than later what you
actually enjoy and make sure that weaves
throughout every job decision you make
I've been doing what I actually enjoy
for 23 years and I can count on one hand
the number of Sunday night blues I've
had to suffer through that is a measure
of success secondly success is
prioritizing well if the word priority
is defined as the most important thing
that then at any one time each of us has
five to seven most important things
this isn't physically spiritually or
even humanly possible now while doing
one thing at a time isn't happening for
any of us knowing your priorities and
force ranking them is worthwhile your
priorities when you walk off this stage
are going to be different than your
priorities next year and your priorities
in five years but have them nonetheless
I try our tried prioritizing things a
lot of different ways but none of them
worked for me before I landed on my own
approach
I am inordinately clear that I am a wife
first
a mother second and an executive third
now my priorities aren't and shouldn't
be yours and thankfully the planet has a
pretty clear way of telling us what our
priorities should be for listening
in my case those came in the form of
divorce papers and two children who
called the nanny mama if you remember
nothing else today remember this no one
not me not a company not a coach not a
partner not a book not a podcast no one
gives you work-life balance you have to
figure out your own version and take it
next success is walking the walk the
people working for you and you will have
a lot over your journey or whole people
with whole lives whether you like it or
not you are part of those lives what
role do you want to play midway through
my career I did one of those 360 reviews
where your peers and your boss and your
direct reports rate your perform
I'll never forget the moment that I
learned that there wasn't a single
person who didn't want me on a project
because it would have a clear vision a
solid strategy and I would execute
flawlessly but every person who was
responded was also resounding ly clear
that no one would enjoy it this feedback
pulled me up short and permanently
changed me as a leader bringing a
compassion joy and understanding to my
leadership style that has made me a
better leader and a happier person now
for those of you motivated by
achievement and I count myself amongst
you you should know that people are far
more productive and motivated in an
environment of trust and respect than an
environment of fear but all the fancy
platitudes and monday-morning
inspirational quotes and foosball
championships are undone the moment your
actions don't match your words walk the
walk and when you mess up and you will
be self-aware enough to own it apologize
and move everyone on and while we're on
the topic of people in today's digital
world never underestimate the power of a
handwritten thank-you note success is
asking for help you will fall down
multiple times and the stronger more
confident more traditionally successful
you are the harder you'll fall know it's
coming and don't be afraid of it success
means taking risks speaking up raising
your voice and writing your own rules
but along the path don't mistake it make
the mistake of ik waiting asking for
help with weakness I did four years and
then I came across the problem that I
couldn't figure out on my own and I
opened myself up to my community both
personally and professionally and got
comfortable saying help in addition to
achieving great results once I figured
out that I couldn't do it on my own and
that was mainly me figuring it out
because everybody else already knew it I
began to see how much more could be
achieved when everyone swimming in the
same direction success is questioning
the status quo
don't ever stop asking why don't quiet
yourself because something is outside of
your swimlane or above your paygrade our
world is changing at such a rapid speed
in every aspect of our human experience
that nothing nothing is beyond our
scrutiny this approach is how you will
differentiate yourself and provide the
most value at any organization you start
or join and if you encounter one that
doesn't value it run don't walk to a new
place change is possible everywhere you
look
decades-old industries are being
reinvented how we communicate shop eat
save give back are all undergoing change
or are ripe for change be part of it in
any way large or small questions
question question especially if someone
says that's just the way it's always
been
lastly measure your success through your
level of passion not your level of
achievement the world you are entering
in less than an hour as a newly minted
MBA is filled with more dynamism
fundamental change opportunity challenge
needs fear and excitement than any world
we've experienced in our lifetime what
the world needs from each of you is your
passion and thankfully the thing that
can bring you the most success is the
opportunity to unleash that passion
don't let anyone or anything take that
from you most notably yourself nothing
kills passion faster than a model of
success that calls for a traditional
definition of achievement let your
passion be your measure of achievement
that will make you a contributing member
of society and a new model of success
now I'm not sure if these measures of
our contribution to society meet my
father's intent but my own experience
has taught me that they are the only
measures of success I want or need for
my husband for my children for my
colleagues and peers for myself and for
each of you the work ethic that got you
through the last few years you're clear
commitment to your ongoing growth and
development and your demonstrated
passion and enthusiasm to make an impact
ensures you are poised to succeed when
you leave here today make it a success
that you can feel proud of not in your
most public moments when it's easy to
bask in the glow of others praise but in
the moments where you are alone with
yourself be successful to the world but
also in your heart and in your mind in
the purest and truest way that you know
how congratulations to your family and
friends for their part in your journey
to this incredible achievement and most
importantly congratulations to each of
you you will leave here today and begin
your next chapter with confidence heart
and a drive for success and I wish you
all the best of luck thank you
[Applause]
big congratulations to the three MBA
classes of 2017 it is so nice to see so
many of my personal former students
under the ten and I'm very very proud of
your way achievement congratulations
also to my colleague Paul Bob and Paul
for receiving the commitment for
excellence a world well deserved
four years ago the MBA class of 2013
bestowed the commitment of excellence
award to Professor Maha Mohammed who
accepted it in person
the following year the MBA class of 2014
bestowed the commitment to excellence
award again to professor Muhammad Ahmad
unfortunately not home could not
personally accept the prize as he passed
earlier in the year his wife Maya and
daughter Shirley who is with me today
accepted the prize on his behalf
another stop for second and make another
congratulations will to Chile who is
graduating this week from Columbia
Business School doctoral program and
becoming
a marketing professor at that school in
Philadelphia professor Nakamura Ahmad
was a gifted scholar amazing teacher and
a beloved friend for everyone
he was my personal mentor for almost 30
years after his untimely passing we
wanted to ensure that his memory stayed
with us and with the school forever
we also wanted to capture neurons unique
personality and qualified qualities into
his memorial two things came to mind now
whom was the best in everything he did
Anna whom had a great passion for
teaching in particular in Hamburg
so his friends at the accounting
division initiate the nom de Melamed
memorial world the highest honor given
at the recognition ceremony to a
graduating student from each class in
the executive mba program the recipient
have demonstrated exceptional academic
skills as well as a significant impact
on the Columbia community each of
today's three awardees will receive
above and beyond the great honor a check
in the amount of $2,000 this is the
first time the NACA Malamud a world is
awarded the recipients for the ember'
New York 2017 class is searching Jindo
[Applause]
the recipients for the Empire miracles
class of 2017 is Salman no Ali
[Applause]
and last but not least the recipient for
the ember new york 2017 friday saturday
class is Nadia a sweetie
[Applause]
thank you
will now announce the academic
excellence awards students who
demonstrate exceptional academic
performance and are in the top 5% of
their class graduate with Dean's honors
with distinction as I call your names I
would ask that you please stand near
your seats to be recognized the
following students will graduate with
Dean's honors with distinction for the
EMS Sachin Jindal Custis care umbilicus
Lobby Nadella J Peterson
and Mohit Singler
the following students will graduate
with Dean's honors with distinction for
the Americas Salman or Ali the following
students will graduate with Dean's
honors with distinction for the BAS
Nadya Afridi Lea - car
Andrew Redman galata Co Milwaukee Kato
Stephanie Renee may George Peters jr.
and Matthew James Toronto our next
Awards of the Ethan our Hannah very
student representative Awards the Ethan
our Hannah berry student representative
Awards are presented to the elected
academic cluster career honor board and
women in business student
representatives to recognize their
dedication to serving the interests of
their classmates and to the overall
betterment of the Executive MBA program
the dean's office has named these awards
for Ethan our Hannah berry who
successfully led to school Demba
programs as well as other critical areas
of the school before he retired as I
read your names please stand in your
seats to be recognized for your
leadership and service to the ember'
community the representatives for eeehm
are Daniel Bruin Rebecca Kalman
[Applause]
Lindsay chalk jennifer Dorland chip
Heilman Nancy Kaplan
Nana Mensa June Oh Lokesh story Sarah
Singson Liz some push tota Vanessa Varys
and Cathy Dewes the representatives for
America's are fastened Ali
Adrian Eisenstaedt our zoo booster II
Miranda Davis kadar Ganta Salima Russ
tool and Michael Ryan southern
[Applause]
the representatives for BA are Fahad
Ahmet Lauren Anderson Julie Bailey for
Sean stop safe Parag Riley yepsen
Keating John Massey Nicole sand reto
Connelly Xavier Segura and meha secory
[Applause]
the Executive MBA distinguished service
award is presented to a graduating
student from each class selected by
classmates as deserving special
recognition for contributions to the
spirit and achievement of the class the
M Bannu York Saturday class has chosen
Lokesh ory to receive the Distinguished
Service Award
[Applause]
the Americas class has chosen salman nor
ali to receive distinguish their before
[Applause]
the executive the MB New York Friday
Saturday class has chosen Fahad Aziz
Hamed see receive the distinguished sir
so now the time has arrived the names of
our graduating students will be read by
Felicia Goodman senior associate
director of student and academic affairs
remember and declan McCarroll and the
director of the Ember global and in the
Americas programs we kindly ask the
audience to remain seated
so that thought the names of all of our
graduates can be read and hurt
all right
there you we will begin by reading the
graduates of the M Binet orc Saturday
class of 2017
Philippe Elvis Nyanza Aurora Heather
McLean spinny megan is bloomer
Elia Bazin's on Daniel Bruin hi Bachchan
Rebecca Kalman Michael Castelli Isaac
Cecil one Esteban Cervantes Victor Chan
Winnie Chan Daphne
Chang Lindsay chalk Angela Lily
- Toni Cottone Ram Sui Stratford Dennis
Patrick deep katarzyna DOMA gala
Jennifer Dorland Courtney or colino
Robert fama Shahrukh fit a con fook we
Jonathan us
Ashley Halpern and Parker hammock Cory
Hartwick chip Hallman Aki's orphan Alan
Jenkins Sechin Jindal Philip why Jay
King
Danny cow
Nancy Lisa Kaplan hostess Karen Salinas
honey kebap Gian Tom Thomas Cory Henry
Kim Jonathan Kim Steven Kim Arwin
kolleru Eric COO young slay Joe Jamie
Lee Ming Lee Albert :
Kareem Master Ani Sameer Malhotra pitar
Markovic Alex Mallin
James McAvoy Varun Meza Nana
yeah - Chiwa Mensa
Justin and mess Eugene beckalus Akash
Modi Nathan Morris
Ravi Nadella Manu G Nathan pit Mughal
rot June
Oh Lokesh re Christopher or maria laura
pace dr. ana see Pavlik J Peterson
Probab rock rrah Dileep Rao Kiran Kumar
Raya pootie
Jeremy reams Michael Edward Redmond
Jared K Richardson Alan room Anika Wyatt
Rousseau Justin Saltzman
[Music]
Russell Schmidt Brian Michael Scully
Sunil coelom study Johann no sure sidwa
bohat Singla sarah Singson caitlin snow
Liz sung kushti ogia Eric Tolkien Shane
tour Chiana Ryan Michael trainer
Abhinav chutney Vanessa varus Kim
Fischer Warren
Allyson Wilner Nick Shaw why a shoe
Christine you Zack
Zachariah Lance
ciao Cassie to Brad sucker
we will now read the names of the
graduates of the Americas class of 2016
Adrian Eisenstaedt
Vicent ali series Scanlon Appel Diego
are RISP a rupak Bhattacharya are zooboo
3d arm Cabrini Carl Williams serve own
Ricardo Costa Miranda Davis saya Dempsey
William C Deng kadar gonta Brian Charles
Griggs Naima hook a Brar our pits Jane
a maiya Nadkarni Kenneth Allen Nelson
the second Salman nor Ali
Monica pool
Eric quirk
Salima Carozza rasool' Gotham's octave
Esteban solder a yoga Melissa
Sandvik Torres David mark spell Berg
Jeremy Stern Alexandra Valencia Rebecca
van de pierre pierre Swan
Michael Ryan southern
we will now read the names of the
graduates of the MV New York Friday
Saturday class of 2017
Nadia shibano of free d irene a julia
Fahad Aziz Ahmed Aaron Allen Lauren
Ashley Anderson a myth Aurora
[Music]
Byron William Austin Danielle Austin
Julie Bailey Sarah Birla Benjamin
Bradford Jennifer Broadbent
Patrick brown mark cabeza
[Applause]
Jeffrey kasseri no excel catch long
Janet Kay joy
Jeffrey Michael Colette
James Crowley Dana and curry
Ranjit died AMA aundrea dude oh no Henry
salubrious Prashant das Dave alhelou
Abby allahi liad ishka safe Parag bill
field
Ritchie Fleischmann Joseph Florio
Giovanni gasps Ian Avery Baird keshu he
Herman Garcia
Michael genteel Felix Gil
Bradley Gordon blaze Goswami Priscilla
Guevara Andrew Redman Galata Jose Ramon
Gutierrez alia Hassan Daniel Hattie
Rachel Hawkins
Carolyn Heisler Jacqueline G Henderson
Thomas Edward Hendrix
Noah Hoffman Eduardo oh god oh
Ryan Thomas Hogan Sarah Sibley Xiu Qi
and who Lauren
Hubert Ursula Lauren Hurley Raphael
Eduardo varela Ison Nikolai's Jensen
[Music]
Daphne Johnson Clinton Kukai owner calar
[Applause]
Tomoaki Quito Daniel cats Riley Yepsen
Keating
oh and Kylie Jackie
Kim Shawn Kim - hun Kim ad King max
Klein Tom Knapp Lauren Dugdale Lieberman
Alex Leah's Karen Lewis Smith
Louisa Loretto Amelia Manderscheid Danny
Mansukhani
Francesca Marchand Z John Massey Robert
maccheroni Stephanie Rene may John
McWade Michael Paul misciagna Debnath
moong dal su-kam Mortensen
Kate Moss from jimson mu Akari
Jake Murphy Stephen Murphy Claire Marie
Bryce Nance's Nasir nizami cuejoe oh wow
Seuss our foe
Diana Perez Antonio Perugino George
Peters jr. james patrick Philbin the
fourth will Plaza Jeffries hope Natalya
poeple Shaheen Rana
Romeo Rho J Jeremy's Rhodes
Ricardo Robert Marcos Romasanta Trevor
Thomas Russo Shawn Riker
[Music]
Melanie Carol Samper Nicole
Sandra doe Connelly Xavier Segura neigh
ha se Cree Calvin Chen Charles Shi Shen
Rahul Shetty Satoshi shimazaki Brian
Smith Zack Solomon arpan Somani as their
song naba Tom Stern felt Victoria
summers Matthew son Matthew James
Toronto Andrew Turner Charles Thompson
crystal Thompson
[Music]
Kevin Isaiah Thomson Anissa Timothy
Caesar
[Applause]
[Music]
Sarah - blonde scott-vincent Townsend
olya Chekhov Alina chun-yin Christian
Val crcel Ramon veloute knee
Bryant wing Nicholas Webber trip Webber
Kevin wife
[Applause]
seeing John you and Cynthia Jiang
please join us in applauding the
Cratchit
okay I know that I stand in the somewhat
unenviable position of the last thing
between their ceremony and your
reception I thank all of you for the
handshakes it was the only time I was
warm this morning so thank you for that
it's always a pleasure to to see so many
of you have had the direct pleasure of
working with I just wanted to leave you
with a thought you've heard lots of
things today and congratulations again
to all of you but I'm probably aware
that somebody somewhere told you that
something you're interested in after
this ceremony you know you shouldn't do
that the best days are in the past and I
want you never ever to believe them I'm
going to close with a story some years
ago when I worked in the government I
was coming back from Japan with a
Japanese colleague we were working on a
trade agreement together it was called
the trans-pacific partnership we're
still kind of working on it it was a
long time ago we landed at Dulles Field
and we were taking a taxi into the
Capitol to brief members of Congress and
we passed the Library of Congress on
which is written past is prologue my
Japanese counterpart turned to me and
asked me what that meant and I started
going into one of my long-winded college
professor II kind of riffs
the cab driver kind of lost it and
turned around and said you ain't seen
nothing yet
that's what we have in mind for you
congratulations again No
we are going to recess the Unseld plaza
across campus if you could wait for the
graduates to go out with all of us first
and then grab your umbrellas and join us
it is under a tent we will see you there
[Music]